From the depths of that mold to the world . Mir gegenüber, Stefan, Death Death Death Teaser. Du denkst, das läuft auf Rock FM. Das ist eine Musikrichtung, wo du jetzt denkst, als Pop-Hörer, wirklich, also Basic-Ass-Pop-Hörer, denkst du, das wäre Rock FM? Das läuft hinter den Clubtüren, durch die ich nicht komme, wo man mich abweist, wo man sagt, kurze Hose mit Garfield-Print, nein, da denke ich mir stellt sowas. Also Taylor Swift-Shirt, du hast Swifty auf der Stirn tätowiert. Und dann werde ich abgelehnt und weißt du, was ich dann sage? Just shake it off. Shake it off. Dann hopfst du so weg auf die Tanzfläche im anderen Club und alle Girls. Ich bin auch der Einzige, der komplett alleine in den Club geht. Natürlich nicht so Deadmold, natürlich die berüchtigste Band aus Deadmold und die uns hier ein bisschen die Klänge gegeben haben. Aber ein bisschen reingespielt haben. Die uns zu oft reingespielt haben. Bisschen. Wir wären auch ohne euch reingekommen, aber danke, dass ihr dabei wart. Ich glaube, also bei uns war es auch noch so, dass man, wenn man sozusagen Pop-Punk gemacht hat oder sowas, da kann man nach der Bühne noch sagen, cooler Auftritt, Jungs, guter Auftritt, Boys. Aber wenn jemand so Death Metal-Maze unterwegs ist, ist es weird danach zu sagen, ihr habt's wieder gerockt, ihr habt's wieder Männer, kommt mal her, lasst euch mal drücken oder so auf diese typischen Theaterrieten, dieses Umarm und Tttt. Genau, die Rosen den Blumenstrauß dann geben von der Oma, von der Tante, die fanden es ganz fantastisch, die fanden es richtig gut. Oma war richtig begeistert. Tante Erna ist ja extra gekommen aus Giebelbrück und der hat es ganz fantastisch gefallen. Echt, aus Giebelbrück extra hergekommen? Ja. Und welche Song war ihr Lieblingssong? Death by Ninety Nails hat ihr richtig gut gefallen und Death in the Willow hat ihr auch richtig gut gefallen. Ich mochte Death by a Thousand Wolves war mein Lieblingssong. Death by a Two Thousand Wolves. Na, mir hat dann Death by Three Thousand Rhinoceroses dann doch noch ein bisschen besser gefallen. Gar nicht gefallen hat mir Death by Allergy. Das ist mein Thema gerade. Allergy? Ja, Death by Allergy, is that a thing? Gibt's das? Das wäre der unnümlichste Tod. Angenommen, du stirbst an Allergie, soll ich was anderes als Vorwand geben? Ja, bitte, auf jeden Fall. Kann man in sein Testament schreiben, pass auf, egal wie ich sterbe, bitte sagt, dass ich irgendwie, während ich versucht habe, in ein brennendes Haus über den Schornstein einzusteigen, um die darin noch sich befindenden kleinen Katzen zu retten, bin ich leider gestorben. Bin ich über einen Nagel, also so ein Nagel, ich reingenagelt wurde. Tetanus-Nagel gestolpert, also bitte impft euch und ich war ein Held. Diese Geschichte kann Twists and Turn-ins haben, auch uncooled Twists, ist mir egal, als kleine Kätzchen hat mich dann doch gebissen in die Achillessehne. Ihr Vater ist in der Chili-Cheese-Nugget-Fabrik in den riesigen Topf heißen Käse gefallen und Und anstatt rauszuklettern, hat er sich dafür entschieden, so viel zu essen, wie es geht, während er schrie, je mehr ich esse, desto einfacher kann ich rausklettern, obwohl alle anderen Fabrikarbeiter gesagt haben, kletter einfach raus, da ist eine Leiter. Letzten Endes ist er daran erstickt, dass er so viel Käse gegessen hat. Nee, es war eine Allergie. Es war eine Birkenpollenallergie. Ach so. Oh. Wir sagen die Beerdigung lieber ab. Wir haben extra, wir kehren das so unter den Teppich. Stehen Todesgründe auf Grabstein? Zum Glück nicht. Nee, aber ich glaube wirklich nicht, oder? Nein. Todesgrund? Das ist doch eigentlich was man... Todesgrund und dann so ein Pfeil zu dem Grab nebenan. Ja, er hat mich umgedacht, er hat mich gekriegt. Nee, aber das wäre doch eigentlich spannend. Also ich weiß nicht, wie oft du auf Friedhöfen bist, nicht so häufig, aber ich weiß noch, wenn man als Kind wird, man dann so drüber geschleppt, über Friedhöfe, wird man so auf dem Asphalt langgezogen, über Friedhöfe. Da will ich ja schon gerne wissen, was ist da passiert. So ein bisschen, ja, so ein QR-Code. Was ist die Geschichte von Marianne Gröbner? Genau, wurde 67, okay, ist alt, ein bisschen jung, aber gut, was ist passiert? Kann noch alles passieren, Gabelstapler ist noch nicht ausgeschlossen mit 67, die rennte heutzutage, da ist ja noch einiges zu sagen. Aber ich meine, so ein Friedhof kann ja auch eine Bildungsstätte sein, dass man lernt, mach das nicht, dann soll mein Tod zumindest jemandem die Hilfe helfen, den gleichen Fehler zu vermeiden. Ich verstehe auch, dass man nicht auf dem Grabstein will, aber es reicht doch zum Beispiel so kleine Infotafeln vorm Grab, wo draufsteht, ganz komplett unrelated jetzt zu dem Grab da vorne. Es steht einfach nur hier, wir haben es hier hingestellt, fast nicht in Steckdosen. Steckdosen, nein, nein. Füchse sehen süss aus, können aber tödlich beißen. Lasst euch gegen Tollwut impfen. Das hat nichts, ich wiederhole, nichts mit Herbert Marquardt zu tun, der hier gerade vor uns liegt. Das ist ein Zufall. Ich überlege aber jetzt auch, was mich nach meinem Tod auszeichnen wird. Ich bin jetzt, ich sag mal so. Deine Messerscharfe Comedy? Entweder das oder, dass ich mittlerweile auch als Klingelkahl durch die Gegend laufe, denn ich klimpere, ja, ich klimpere. Dir ist es vielleicht schon aufgefallen, ich bin Kleingeld-Johnny. Du bist hier reingeklimpert. Ich hab dich von zehn Kilometern, hab schon kommen hören, du bist hier reingeklimpert. Ich arbeite so ein bisschen an meiner Coolness und mir hat jetzt auch geholfen. Nach unten, du bist der Einzige, der nach unten an der Coolness arbeitet. Okay, zu cool. Die Investoren sagen, das fliegt uns doch um die Ohren. Das glaubt niemand mehr. Dieser Coolness-Kurs. Und geholfen hat mir natürlich der aktuelle, gehen wir kurz in die Rubrik? Wir gehen in die Rubrik. Das Marte-Update. Die modernen Trends. Und in der neuesten Folge des Marte-Upe-linge-linge-linge-linge-linge-dinge-den Trends.
Und in der neuesten Folge des Marte-Updates kann ich versichern, ich habe ja lange erzählt, die aktuelle Marte-Situation ist folgende, 1,90 Euro bei meinem Lieblingskiosk.
Der sagt, die alten Podcast-Uferhörerinnen und Hörer erinnern sich, der immer sagt, lecker lecker, nee, lecker Marte, es war lecker Marte, also guck mal, ich habe die Lore selber nicht mehr gelesen. Aber Leckermate immer sagt, als du es gekauft hast, weshalb du dich ja lange Zeit entschieden hast, nicht mehr hinzugehen. Genau, jetzt allerdings hat er entweder seine Frau oder eine Mitarbeiterin, ist jetzt auch oft an der Kasse und ich versuche das jetzt so abzupassen vom Timing. Ich versuche da für ihre penible Excel-Tabellen. Oh, seine Tante. Genau, die Tante. Ich verstehe jetzt nicht, warum du sagst, seine Frau oder eine Mitarbeiterin, aber dazwischen gibt es wirklich, hast du alles so Sherlock Holmes mässig ausgeschlossen. Nichte schliesst sich mittlerweile aus. Ich habe die beiden lange genug beobachtet und das ist keine Nichte Onkel Situation. Sehr gut. Man erkennt ja manchmal so Beziehungen, sind die zusammen, sind das. Bei Onkel Nichte ist es super schwer zu erkennen, weil nicht mal unbedingt Blutsverwand. Ja, aber da finde ich, das hat schon so einen eigenen Flavor und das sehe ich da auf gar keinen Fall nicht.
Genau wie Stepdad.
Zeigt mir 100 Nichten und 100 Onkel und ich kann dir sagen, wer mit wem.
Schläft?
Nein.
Verwandt ist.
Verwandt ist. Ja, okay.
Das ist dann Staffel zwei, wenn sie es etabliert.
Fang doch nicht direkt an damit.
Nee, ich meine nur, weil du es so erzählt hast. Wir müssen Guido Kanz irgendwie auf die Seite bringen, wir können ja nicht sofort sagen. Warum pitchst du immer nur so Sexsendungen? Nee, ich weiß nicht, das klang jetzt gerade so. Es war jetzt ... Vielleicht ganz unangenehm, aber auf jeden Fall kann ich jetzt relativ gut davon ausgehen, dass die Person nicht drin ist. Und jetzt wurde es aber erhöht von 1,90 Euro auf 2 Euro. Und ihr kennt mich, ich habe immer einen passenden Bargeldturm dabei, um zu zahlen, wenn es heisst 1,90 Euro. Ich kenne den Preis. Du schaffst ja deine Probleme selber. Ich tauche dort auf. Du schaufelst ja ein eigenes Grab. Mit dreimal 50 Cent, zweimal 20 Cent. Du sählst am eigenen Ast. Gebe ich ab. Jetzt aber, Pottblitz aus dem Nichts, wurde der Preis erhöht auf 2 Euro. Da stand ich natürlich mit meinen 1,90 Euro erstmal dumm da, aber die kennen mich natürlich, Kulanz, denen ist natürlich genauso unangenehm, dass der Preis sich erhöht wie mir, dass ich nicht genug dabei habe, haben gesagt, passt schon nächstes Mal dann zwei Euro. Und ab jetzt habe ich natürlich die Möglichkeit, weil ihr wisst, ich habe einen riesigen Eimer Kleingeld und lange war meine Idee, ich zahle das ganze Geld irgendwann ein, bin reich, kaufe mir einen Personal Assistant, kaufe mir einen Hubschrauber, habe eine grosse Firma, vielleicht ein Medienimperium, lasse mir ein cooles Intro komponieren, trage massgeschneiderte Anzüge und dann dachte ich mir, bin ich halt so, also gut, vielleicht merkt man, ich habe auch gerade Succession abgeschlossen, aber ich dachte mir, sobald dieser Eimer eingezahlt ist, bin ich Candle Roy. Was ja gerade so der Megatrend ist, was da besprochen wird vom Feuilleton, ist ja dieses stille Reichtum, was die in ihren Outfits sagen. Es hat einen Namen, den habe ich natürlich vergessen, aber es geht darum, Subtle Rich sein, es geht darum, dass die Outfits irgendwie sowas, ich weiß nicht. Ich präge Begriffe, ich kenne sie nicht. Hashtag Subtle Rich Gate. Aber die Outfits der Leute da, die tragen ja nicht gross. Nee, die haben keinen Geldschein im Revers. Sondern die haben ganz, ganz sleek gut sitzende Sachen, die keine, wo keine Markennamen unbedingt draufstehen. Und ich finde das fantastisch, weil das lässt mich jetzt die andere Phase überspringen. Schliess sich der Geist quasi. So habe ich mich auch angezogen. Ich versuche auch immer Basic-Ass-Shirts zu tragen, wo die einigermaßen gut sitzen und wo nicht irgendwie gross etwas draufsteht. Das heisst, das ist total clever für mich, dass mir da so ein Trend einfach entgegenkommt. Die Reichen müssen sich einfach anfangen, so anzuziehen wie ich. Mich anziehe bereits.
Okay, verstehe. Aber meinst du, die machen das aktiv, um dir entgegenzukommen?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, die wollen nicht ... Ich glaube, denen ist es inzwischen peinlich, dass die ganzen krassen Crazy-Marken, so Balenciaga, Louis Vuitton und so ...
Oder um noch weitere zu nennen.
Nenn nur drei, um weitere zu nennen. Eston, Madden, Calimero. Calimero zum Beispiel. Fred, Feuerstein. alle, Frankreich, um nur ein paar zu nennen. Und die, und was mir aufgefallen ist aber, ohne jetzt wahnsinnig drin zu sein in der Model-Lore, aber ich glaube, die nervte ist, dass die immer dick ihre Markennamen draufschreiben. Und ich dachte inzwischen, ah, die machen keine Mode mehr, die machen Merge. Krasse Marken machen Merge, so können mich die GQ oder die Vogue gerne zitieren, machen Merge für sich selbst. Was ist das Zitat nochmal? Du hast jetzt einen riesigen Klammer-Einschub gehabt, der passt nicht aufs Cover. Ich hätte gehofft, irgendjemand wird so ein Lektor oder Lektorin, wird das ja wohl nicht so machen. Du hast neben dem Riesenbild von dir selbst auf dem Cover von GQ nicht so viel Platz. Die sind zufällig entstanden in der Woche. Das ist nicht zufällig entstanden, du hast Tigerbaby im Arm. Ja, das war da, das lief durch Ehrenfeld, dieses Tigerbaby.
Also nochmal das Zitat bitte.
Das Zitat ist, und jetzt muss man mich dann nochmal irgendwie sauber machen, ein paar Kommas raus machen und vielleicht was gerade rücken.
Die grossen Marken machen nur noch Merch.
Okay.
Checkt man das schon?
Punkt oder Semikolon, was ist?
Fragezeichen. Okay. Ist zu wenig selbstbewusst vielleicht. vielleicht. Wir machen ja auch Merch. Stimmt nicht ganz. Ihr macht unser Merch, denn ihr habt die Möglichkeit, ich muss das einfach jetzt nutzen, denn ihr habt die Möglichkeit, eure tollen Designs einzuschicken mit dem UFO, das ihr kennt. Oder auch eure schlechten. Oder schlechte oder mittelmässig. Einfach mal die ganzen Ordner hoch und runter. Wir haben alle verschiedene Ordner. Wir wollen sie sehen.
Es sehen ja noch wie nur wir, ja, uns kann man noch vertrauen. Ihr schickt uns auch eure Intros. Und also schickt sie gerne vorbei und falls es uns gefällt, drucken wir es aufs T-Shirt, schicken es euch und alle anderen können es auch kaufen. Also, falls ihr Bock habt, schickt gerne noch einen, ihr habt bis Ende Juli ...
Ist das nicht korrekt?
Ihr habt bis Ende Juni-Zeit.
Diese verdammten Monate.
Juni, Julo, Juli. Ist nicht korrekt. Ja, bis Ende Juni-Zeit. Diese verdammten Monate. Juni, Julo, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, Juli, da kann man die nicht zumindest ein bisschen entzerren. Junong und Juloch. Kann man die nicht zumindest ein bisschen entzerren. Pack da mal Oktober dazwischen oder so. Juni, Oktober, Juli, das ist nicht so direkt. Das ist doch noch verwirrender, weil so ist ja, ich glaube, die haben uns zusammengeschoben, damit es fast egal ist. Ach so, damit du sagst, es ist in der Nähe, es landet in der Nähe. Wenn du in der Woche verrutscht, wenn du sagst, ich bin am Ende Juni und dann ist es falsch, im Urlaub, es ist grob in der Ecke. Niemand sagt, ah, okay, er hat sich komplett vertan, er fährt erst im Oktober. Weißt du, deswegen haben wir es zusammengeschoben, damit der, es ist ein marginaler Fehler. Vielleicht war es früher ein riesiges Problem, weil es genau um sechs Monate dazwischen war und alle völlig durcheinander waren. Ja, was fährst du über Weihnachten weg? Hä, nein, Jomo. Ach so. Jomo. Oh Gott. Nicht Jolmo. Oh Gott. Früher hieß das auch anders, natürlich etymologisch korrekt. So, und jetzt kostet die Mate zwei Euro. Ach, davon. Jetzt denke ich mir natürlich, jetzt habe ich die Chance, weil dieser Geldeimer, der früher mal eine Wertanlage war, würde jetzt eher zur Last. Aber mit zwei Euro denke ich mir, jetzt habe ich natürlich die Möglichkeit, jede Woche, wenn ich hierher zur Aufnahme gehe und mir eine Mate hole, kann ich zehn Münzen wegbringen. Zehn mal zwanzig Cent. Jetzt sag du mir, ab wann wird es dreist, kann man jemandem jede Woche mit Anlauf mit Anlauf abhusten. Ich merke schon, wie ich subtil dich da hingehend habe, abzuhusten. Ich hasse das, wenn Leute denken, sie haben eine coole Stimme, ihr habt dann keine coole Stimme. Also, was kannst du mir raten? Klingt einfach, als ob ihr abhusten müsst. Zehn zwanzig Cent-Stücke. Oh my God, I hate it. Also kann ich 10, 20 Cent-Stücke mitnehmen, oder ist es zu viel?
Ich hätte niemals abhusten dürfen.
Habe ich gefragt.
Ist es zu viel, oder würdest du sagen, ab wann wird es dreist, mit zu viel Kleingeld zu zahlen?
Zu viel Kleingeld zu zahlen, ich glaube, es ist nicht dreist.
Ich glaube, die freuen sich über Kleingeld, gerade Kiosks freuen sich über Kleingeld. Danke, dass du zahlst. Gerne. Ich wollte dich extra nicht in die Richtung leiten, weil ich weiß, dass du Lehm in meiner Hand bist und deswegen wollte ich dich bewusst nicht manipulieren und deswegen freut es mich sehr, dass du das von selber gesagt hast, ohne dass ich im Vorhinein auf dich eingewirkt habe, oder? Nee, hast du gar nicht, hast du gar nicht. Kannst du das... Kurz. Du musst jetzt so Assoziationsfragen stellen, weißt du, wie wir Lügen-Detektor-Test. Das hängt ja auch an mit, wie heisst du und so. Genau, wie heissen Sie? Stefan. Stefan. Okay, wir haben jetzt hier schon mal einen Ausschlag auf dem Leben getagter. Ja, gut, aber heiße ich halt. Vielleicht ist er falsch eingestellt, vielleicht ist er genau falsch eingestellt. Das ist uns schon mal passiert, ja, aber das, seitdem haben wir das Gericht. Und dann ist er mal in den Knast gekommen, oder was? Ja. Wegen Ihnen, weil das falsch eingetellt war. Ich stelle hier die Fragen. Welches Wetter ist heute? Sehr heiß, unangenehm heiß. Ich habe wieder einen Ausschlag. Ja, aber ich finde es heiß. Ja, aber ihr Körper anscheinend nicht. Wie finden Sie es heiß? Ich finde es okay. Sie finden es okay? Was finden Sie heiß? Ich finde es ziemlich heiß. Dann müssen wir sich aber darauf etwas was einstellen. Ja, okay. Nennt mal so, wir leben jetzt in der Welt der wandelnden Temperaturen, ja? Wie Sie das heiß finden? Hier steht sie Lügen. Ich hab sie auch angeschlossen. Leugnen Sie, glauben Sie an den Klimawandel, glauben Sie an den Menschen gemachten Klimawandel. Es gibt ja unterschiedliche Aus... Einfach mit Ja, Nein antwortAntworten. Je... Hm. Ausschlag. Drei, drei, drei Töne sind Lüge? Warte. Schwörst du, dass ich dir nicht manipulativ vorgehalten habe, dass du das sagen sollst, sondern das aus freien Stücken tust? Ähm, ja. Das erste Mal in deinem Leben hast du die Wahrheit gesagt. Und deswegen freue ich mich natürlich jetzt. Und jetzt, das erste Mal nach all der Zeit, gehe ich zum Kiosk geschlossen. Und ich bin jetzt natürlich die Klimperkuh, die jetzt hier mit 10, 20 Cent-Stücken durch ganz Köln flanieren muss, wie so ein Cowboy. Daher kommt übrigens der Begriff Klimperkuh. Für alle, die sich gefragt haben, warum sagt man ständig? Warum sagen die Onkels und Nichten Weihnachten ständig Klimperkuh? Woher kommt das eigentlich? Deswegen haben wir von Quarks und Co. für euch recherchiert und es kommt tatsächlich daher, dass Florentin im Jahr 2023 vor geschlossenen Kiosktüren stand. Ein einmaliges Erlebnis übrigens. Kiosks sind immer offen, man kann sich immer auf die verlassen.
Feiertage, Sonntage.
Wenn ich dann so, ich weiß nicht, 22.30 Uhr oder so,
bin ich mit dem Paket los zu meinem Kiosk, der auch ein Paketshop ist,
ohne nachzudenken, dass es um 22.30 Uhr eine weirde Zeit ist,
um Pakete wegzubringen, aber es ging, ohne Probleme.
Wirklich, das ist ein Komfort, dem ist man sich oft gar nicht bewusst.
Können wir mal kurz einen Shoutout machen an Kioskbesitzer? Ja, ja.fach mal. Schweigeminute, Schweigeklatschen. Ja, Schweigeklatschen ist die beste Idee. Eine Minute lang klatschen. Eine Minute ist so lang. Unfassbar lang, das war jetzt drei Sekunden. Eine Minute ist so insane lang, aber wir können auch schlecht schätzen. Kann man das nicht mal ändern? Schweige, schweige, schweige Dutzend oder so. Es gibt bei Zeit keine... Zwölf Minuten? Dutzend ist auch so weird, als ob zwölf... Du brauchst nichts zwischen zehn und fünfzehn, wirklich nicht. Sagt fünfzehn, ist eine gerade Zahl, super cool, kannst du in jedem Satz gebrauchen. Zehn ist eine super gerade Zahl, noch viel besser, kannst du in jedem Satz gebrauchen, aber du brauchst nichts dazwischen, du brauchst kein Dutzend. Aber ist das ... Fahre nicht halbes Dutzend, sagt fünf. Ohne Scheiss, ey, auf dieses eine Milchbrötchen kommt es jetzt nicht an. Ein Dutzend Milchbrötchen. Ich hasse Dutzend. Auch nur bei Milchbrötchen, aber ich glaube, man sagt, ist Dutzend nicht Code für, ich weiß es nicht. Dutzend Gründe nennen, warum wir das nicht machen sollen. Nenn mir ein Dutzend Modemarken.
Fritt hatte auch mal eine Hose, glaube ich.
Star Wars macht auch Merch Shirts.
Fritt hatte mal eine Hose.
Und jetzt klimper ich durch ganz Köln.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz geil, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt das Gefühl, ich habe ein bisschen an Coolness eingebüsst.
Aber durch dieses Klimpern, das hat einfach so dieses Cowboy-Gefühl. Bei jedem Schritt einfach... Bei denen sind sie Sporen. Bei denen sind sie Sporen. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr nicht. Sporn sagt, du verletzt dein Pferd. Das sagt für mich aus, du bist kein guter Cowboy. Moment, Pferdehygiene. Stopp, stopp, Hot Take, Stefan, alle Cowboys mit Sporen sind keine guten Cowboys? Ja, das kommt auch noch aufs Cover. Wenn du ein guter, das ist der Untertitel des Films. Das ist ein Film? Ich dachte, das ist ein Magazin, okay. Rechte sind schnell zu haben. Ist ein ganzer Film. Und eigentlich, also es geht darum, Cowboys, die coolen Cowboys sind cool mit ihren Pferden, sind cool zu den anderen Tieren, sind halt, und dann geht es darum, dass sie eher Kämpfe führen gegen andere Cowboys. Die Stadt ist nicht groß genug für beide von uns, für beide von uns. Das ist der neue Slogan, weil der alte war schon weg. Und deswegen, weißt du, wie uncool sind denn Leute mit Sporen, die ihre Pferde verletzen müssen? Dressier sie richtig, dass sie cool schnell reiten. Du willst ja eine coole Einheit zwischen Cowboy und Pferd. Ja, ja, okay. Aber ich denke, Sporn sind immer noch die humanere Variante des Geweils. Es gibt ja auch die Peitsche, die Rute beim Pferd. Die ist geil. Das findest du geil? Ja, ja. Okay, dann bin ich eher ein Sporn-Typ. Es gibt moralisch keinen klaren roten Faden in dem Film. Aber ich glaube, das war für Cowboys ein Riesenproblem, weil die wollten unbedingt sporen, weil die so cool sind. Man stellt sich heraus, der hat gar kein Pferd. Und immer so kling, kling, ich glaub die Luft ist mit Blei gewürzt. Ja, Jeffrey, wir wissen alle, dass du kein Pferd hast. Was sagst du? Wir fragen uns, warum du die Sporen hast. Du sagst die ganze Zeit so... Hast du gerade was gegen Jerry Longfinger gesagt? Du heisst auch nicht Longfinger, du heisst Dittrich mit Nachnamen. Man kennt mich hier als Jerry Longfinger. Nein, alle kennen dich als Carl Dittrich. Und wir sind auch nicht in den USA. Du gibst mir zwei Schuss Whisky oder du hast zwei Schuss im Kopf, mein Lieber. Ich sehe den roten Propf und oben, das ist eine Spielzeugpistole. Oh mein Gott, ey. Du hast auch kein Pferd, du fährst ein Ford Car. Okay? Ich werde wiederkehren. Werdere was? Ich werde wiederkehren. Wiederkehren. Kannst du abhusten? Ich werde wiederkehren und mit mir meine ganze Bande, ja, das kannst du mir glauben. Aber ich glaube, es ist echt ein Problem, es ist wirklich ein Problem, dass Leute so tun, sie hätten ein Pferd, nur um die coolen Sporen zu haben. Ich bin ja ein Rucksack-Gei, ich bin Rucksack-Kind, Rucksack-Boy, ich hab den immer am Start. Ich auch. Mein Schlüssel, mein Haustierschlüssel ist immer im Rucksack. Ein Haustierschlüssel. Ja, ich hab eine sehr aggressive Schneeäule, die ein bisschen mehr Sicherheitsaufwand erfordert. Heisst sie Hedwig? Sie heisst Hedwig, aber das war vor dem Film, nach dem Buch, aber vor dem Film. Aber ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen, das kannst du mir nicht beweisen. Es war zwischen den Medien. Das kannst du mir nicht beweisen. Du kannst mir nicht beweisen, dass ich das Buch gelesen habe. Lest keine Bücher, Bücher sind oft spannend. Zu spannend. Ich habe jedenfalls immer einen Rucksack dabei und dachte irgendwann, da ist ja Platz für viel Komfort auch zum Beispiel. Zum Beispiel immer gerne Tic Tacs dabei, fände ich einen coolen Karate-Train. Du hast nämlich zum Beispiel immer Fisherman's Friends dabei, finde ich immer gut, schnore ich mir oft, weil ich denke, jetzt ein frischer Atem, der mich vollends erfrischt und aktiv macht und toll meinen Atem zur Geltung bringen lässt, geil. Und weil du natürlich Kapitän bist. Und weil ich Kapitän Stefan bin, ja. Aber Tic Tac haben natürlich auch diese Sporenprobleme, dass du auch wieder Klimperkuh bist. Ich laufe herum und ich klimpere. Und hat man nicht im Mittelalter, Kinderschänder und so, hat man denen nicht so Klappern hinten dran gemacht, damit die überall auffallen. Das kann sein, ja. Ich glaube, ja. Oder so Pestopfern oder Pestkranken. Ja, oder so. Ich glaube, so was, ja. Genau, man wusste nicht genau Pestopfer oder Pädophil. Du meinst, früher wollte man möglichst leise sein, heute ist es cool, so ein gewisses Ching-Ching dabei zu haben. Wir machen beide den grossen Fehler, dass wir nicht laut sein sollten. Wir wirken wie Sexoffender, wenn wir die ganze Zeit mit so einem Tic-Tac-Ding im Rucksack rumlaufen. Habe ich jetzt noch nicht gehabt, die Assoziation. Aber gut, kann sein. Ich muss mal schauen, wie die Leute mich anschauen. Sie springen dir aus dem Weg. Sie springen dir alle aus dem Weg. Aber nur weil ich sie so prüfen und angucke. Warum guckst du mich an? Ich hatte gerade Kopfhörer im Ohr und bin langgefahren. Plötzlich ein Mann auf einer Bank springt auf, zeigt auf mich und ruft. Und ich habe es nicht gehört und dadurch war es mir auch egal. Weißt du, so... Nein, nein, Moment, Moment. Das ist ein Sidequest. Nee, nee, nee. Da ein Sidequest. Nee, nee, nee. Es gibt auch nonverbale Kommunikation. Aufstehen und zeigen ist wirklich, jetzt hier passiert was. Aber ich bin mit dem Fahrrad gefahren, es war nirgendwo jemand, es war eine leere Strasse, ich bin mit dem Fahrrad gefahren, auf dem Fahrradweg, es kam kein Auto, es war nichts, keine schwierige Situation, ein Mann springt ... Ich komm in den Radius des Mannes, weißt du, was man im Videospiel hat. Ich bin in die Nähe und komme. Genau, diese Range habe ich aktiviert, er springt auf, zeigt auf mich so eine Animatronik in so einem Freizeitpark, in Phantasialand, zeigt ... ja, zeigt, springt auf und macht seinen Mann auf und zu. Und ich habe es einfach ignoriert, weil ich dachte, ich habe gerade keine Zeit für so einen Sidequest. Wenn ich jetzt gerade nicht hier zur Podcastaufnahme gefahren wäre, hätte ich vielleicht da interagiert oder so und gesagt, ja, was kann ich tun, muss ich ihr Feld von den drei Wölfen befreien, okay, dann schreibe ich in den Chat, ich brauche eine Gruppe für den Wolfquest. Dein Mut ist schon über die Landesgrenzen hinaus bekannt, Stefan, das muss man schon sagen, da musst du dir aber auch selber was anschmieren. Okay, weil ich die drei Tutorials gemacht habe. Allerdings, ja, hundert Punkte. Aber hast du danach nicht so ein bisschen an die runtergeguckt und dachtest, was könnte Auslöser dieses Zeigens gewesen sein? Ich habe dann so halbgar so aufs Fahrrad geschlagen, weil ich dachte, irgendwie, vielleicht ist was los am Fahrrad oder so, was mir in die Speichen, was mir droht, in die Speichen zu... Er hat so dreimal den Mund auf und zu gemacht. Ich dachte, es kann nicht sein, du hast mal was in deinen Speichen, das könnte sich gleich verheddern. Achtung, Speichen! Was hätte man sagen können? Würdest du jemals schreien und Leute was warnen? Weil ich glaube, ich kann mich nicht so kurz fassen, dass ich diese... Du hast, sagen wir mal, wenn du streichst in einer Notsituation, du hast zwei, drei Sekunden Zeit, deinen Punkt rüberzubringen. Habe ich noch nie in meinem Leben hinbekommen. Du musst voraus planen, in der Situation vergiss es.
Merk dir, was hätte ich sagen wollen für die nächste Situation.
Ich habe oft ein Problem mit Radfahrern, die ihre Licht zu hoch
eingestellt haben, weil ich bin nachts jetzt auch
unterwegs. Lichthöhe!
Nachts unterwegs und natürlich, du kennst meine Melodramatik,
wenn mir so jemand in der Nacht entgegenkommt.
Ah, ah, ah,
meine Augen, ah!
Und dann sage ich, bitte Licht runter. Bitte Licht runter. Lichthöhe. Und ich sage mittlerweile, also ich traue mir noch nicht so laut zu sagen, dass die Person es hundertprozentig hört. Bist du im Auto? Nein, ich bin zu Fuß. Du bist zu Fuß. Ich bin zu Fuß. Okay. Und dann wirklich schon von Weitem, jetzt will ich mir das Gesicht schmelzen und dann bitte Licht runter. Ich glaube, es hat noch niemand gehört, weil ich nicht so mutig bin, aber ich versuche es zumindest kurz und knackig auszudrücken. Finde ich sehr gut. Aber jetzt, ich klimper durch die Gegend und ich weiß nicht, ob es mich cooler macht. Ich habe jetzt aber auch überlegt, eine andere, eine andere, die ich gerne machen würde für diesen Sommer. Coolness im Sommer ist ein wichtiges Thema. Winter ist coolness egal. Du hast eine Snoopy-Mütze. Du hast drei Anoraks drüber. Drei Anoraks. Diese Mütze auch mit den grossen Schlappohren, an denen noch zwei Seile dran hängen, an denen zwei Bommel dran sind. Im Winter ist alles egal. Du bist verschnitten. Alle haben diese süssen roten Näschen. Im Sommer geben sich alle Mühe, sich möglichst hot auszusehen, im Winter ist allen eigentlich scheißegal. Jetzt im Sommer allerdings, coolen ist wieder wichtig, und was ich jetzt mache, wenn ich auf eine Tür zugehe, dann hebe ich den Arm schon so fünf Schritte zu früh. Das ist mein Move des Sommers. So dass, wenn du auf die Tür zugehst, wirklich schon so eine Art Landeanflug des Arms, und dann mach ich die Tür auf. Wenn jemand im Gegend kommt, denkt der so ... Umso besser. Vor allem die seitliche Hand ist ja die coolste Grusshand der Welt. Wenn du auf jemanden zugehst und du machst die seitliche Hand ... Du bist sofort um den R-Glauben. Also seitlich zu halten, horizontal. Das ist sofort cool. Man trifft niemanden, man trifft keinen Feind. Aber darum geht's nicht, es geht um Lifestyle. Du triffst so, willst du niemals jemanden ... Niemand kann das matchen. Wenn du die Hand vertikal ausstreckst, mach mal. Ich könnte dich niemals ... Niemanden findest du, der sofort so macht. Vor allem, du willst direkt noch die Upper Hand haben. Das gefällt mir dann auch nicht. Genau, aber selbst wenn die eine einschlägt, bist du der absolut Coolste, und wenn nicht, zack die Hand. Aber das ist natürlich auch ein guter Sketch, wenn irgendwie in so einer Mafia-Familie da hättest die Familie nicht verraten sollen. Ja, ich hab... Jetzt, okay, jetzt hab ich... Hat jemand ein Magazin? Nee, wir haben keine Magazine mehr. Hat niemand ein Magazin? Ich hab die Vogue. Nein, ich mein... Ach so. Für den Hit. Was für ein Film war das? Der wierde Film, wo es plötzlich um den Sohn ging, der immer alles falsch versteht. Das ist dein erster Drack in der Familie. Du passt auf und schaust zu, ja? Sorry, ich dachte, du sprachst von Magazin im Sinne von Printprodukt. Nein. Sorry, Vater, ich bin ein Enttäuschendes. Für den Hit hier, für den Snatch. Für den Hit, ah. Für den Crackdown. Snatch war ein Megafilm, aber ein Hit. Für den Crackdown. Ich kann einen Hit anmachen im Radio. Nein, okay. Ich begnadige dich noch mal. Jemand denkt, dass ein Drive-by das Essen bestellen bei McDonalds ist. Ja. Und nicht das Shooting-Drive-by. Das ist mein Schuss übrigens. Ich bin nur Bege, also zwei Finger gerade ausgeschreckt und eine Daumen macht lustige kleine Auf- und Abbewegungen. Der Hahn. Du willst die Mafia von innen umkrempeln. Du bist so Undercover-Cop, der dann sagt, nee, ich glaube, ich kann die umdrehen. Ich glaube so wenig ans Umdrehen, dass ich, ich will nur rein und mich dann korrumpieren lassen. Okay, du willst umgedreht werden. Ich will umgedreht werden. Jetzt gerade denke ich mir, es ist schrecklich, was die machen, furchtbar, aber cool auf eine Art, mal reingucken und dann die von innen zerstören, um dann mich langsam korrumpieren zu lassen. Also ich meine, es muss doch auch Undercover Leute geben, die sagen, kann ich zur Mafia vielleicht? Also, kann ich da mitmachen? Ja, wir hatten eigentlich gedacht, dass Joe dahingeht, weil du guckst so viele Mafia-Filme. Wir haben alle Filme gesehen. Ja eben, du hast diesen ... Ich habe alle Filme gesehen. Aber du hast, bei dir nimmt es überhand, du hast der Partip-Poster an deinem Office hängen und so und wir denken, dass du nicht aus den richtigen Gründen ... Boss, mein ganzes Leben habe ich mich schon darauf vorbereitet, Mann. Du machst mal diese Geste. Ich kenne mich genau aus. Du rauchst viel zu viel. Ich mache den Angebot. Wir haben gesagt, du darfst nicht anrauchen. Wenn du mir doch einmal ein Angebot machst, das ich nicht ablehnen kann. Boss, das muss alles überzeugend sein. Mein ganzes Leben lang gehöre ich schon da rein. Ich gehöre da rein, das ist mein Blut, das ist meine Familie. Familie, also ich verstehe nicht, ich glaube, du willst da rein, weil du eine Mafia sein willst und nicht, weil du eine Coverkoppe sein willst. Ich stehe für die Gerechtigkeit.
Ich kann die umdrehen, von innen her.
Wir dachten eher, dass du bei dem Reitverein,
da hat jemand die Kasse,
da klaut jemand aus der Kasse,
da klaut einer der kleinen Reitermädchen aus der Kasse.
Pferde sind ein schlechtes Zeichen, das weiß ich aus Mafia-Filmen.
Aber gut, Chef, ich mach's.
Okay, okay.
Vielen Dank, ehrlich gesagt. Mega geil, wie kooperativ du bist. Ihr kümmert euch hier um die Pferde, was? Ja, genau. Es fehlen ab und zu zweifelv Euro aus der Kasse. Zwölf Euro? Warum reden sie so? Ihr habt da so eine Hütte. Ich gebe euch jetzt alle ein Kabel, ja? Ich verkabel euch. Warum denn? Okay, hey, hör mir zu. Wenn du eine Ratte nicht fängst, dann fängt sie an zu knabbern. Und eine Ratte, die knabbert, die redet auch, ja? Wie meinen Sie? Ich rede nicht. Du magst sein Pferd? Du magst Amadeus? Alle wissen, dass sie ein Cop sind. Ich bin kein Cop. Ich bin Praktikant an der Pferderennbahn. Okay. Oder hast du ein Problem damit? Willst du meinen Hintergrund? Willst du wissen, wo ich aufgewachsen bin? Meine Hintergrundgeschichte? Kann ich dir geben. Ja, ich mag Amadeus. Du magst Amadeus? Weißt du, wenn du Amadeus nicht mehr mögen würdest? Wenn der Kopf ab in deinem Bett liegt! Okay, wir finden die Ratte. Pferderennbahn. Ja, das war alles auf einer Pferderennbahn. Ich habe gedacht, vor allem Tiere sind so fucking weird und awkward. Oh ja. Weil, wenn man sich so Dokus anschaut, da gibt es ja manchmal so Storylines irgendwie, da verlieren sich Mutter, Reh und Reh-Kids verlieren sich irgendwie und da gibt's so eine kleine Storyline, weil sie weggelaufen sind vor dem Löwen, ich weiß nicht, ob das zusammenpasst jetzt natürlich, aber nur mal jetzt für das Szenario.
Und dann kommen sie wieder zusammen und irgendwie nach Tagen sind sie dann endlich wieder vereinigt und sowas und dann können sie sich nicht sagen, was passiert ist. Tiere können sich nicht sagen, was passiert ist. Sie können sowas ausdrücken wie, ich freue mich sehr, dich zu sehen. Schon klar, Tiere können kommunizieren, Tiere können immer kommunizieren. Völlig, völlig, ich will ja gar nichts, ich höre schon die Hater, Tiere können kommunizieren, die kommunizieren die ganze Zeit, nur weil die nicht so kommunizieren wie ihr, ist das heiß, dass sie nicht kommunizieren. Du bist noch sehr getroffen von deinem Hundeding, dass Hunde sich neigen, um dich besser zu sehen. Tiere können kommunizieren, aber sie können sich nicht erzählen, was passiert ist. Und das macht es fast noch mehr awkward, dass sie sich Dinge, Basic Dinge, wie zu sagen, mir geht es gut gerade, ich freue mich wiederzusehen. Wir treffen uns morgen um zwölf, der eine steht um zwölf da, der andere kommt um sechzehn Uhr und er sagt ... Und du hast keine Chance zu sagen, was für ein Wichser bist du eigentlich, dass du so spät kommst. Ja. Wenn wir so kommunizieren würden wie Tiere, wäre es in etwa so, wir sind so zwei Rehkitze, die sich ewig getrennt haben, dann und dem einen, der ist über ... Wir sind Brüder, wir Geschwister. Genau. Dem einen, der ist über einen Berg, haben sich getrennt, dann hat ein Werwolf, hat ihn getrieben. Sieben Tage und sieben Nächte. Dann kam ein Ufo, hat ihn entführt, kam wieder, ich auch weg, dann war ich in einem Rewe, wusste nicht, wie ich da bin, Menschen sind hier mehr gelaufen, mich rausgesteucht, viele Sachen sind passiert, wir treffen uns wieder und das Gespräch wird in etwa, ah hi, ich freue mich dich zu sehen.
Ich freue mich auch dich zu sehen.
Ah, mega geil.
Wollen wir zum Fluss was trinken?
Wir müssen zum Fluss was trinken.
Ich will trinken.
Aber ich sehe sowas wie Erleichterung in deinem Gesicht.
Ich bin erleichtert, dass du wieder da bist.
Ich auch, ich happen to be erleichtert.
Schön, dass du nicht tot bist.
Das kann man, glaube ich, nicht sagen als Reh.
Selbst das ist so weit.
Man kann nicht...
Aufgeflogenes Undercover-Reh. Man kann … Oh, scheiße. Warum sind sie verkabelt? Ich … äh, nein, glaub mir, hey, hey, hey, hey … Sie sind verkabelt. Sie sind nicht mein … Das haben sie mit meinem Bruder gemacht. Was ich bei solchen Tierlogos am liebsten mag, sind diese Robotertiere. Hm. Diese, diese Robotertiere, wo die dann so einen Pinguin bauen, so einen Roboterpinguin. Mit der Kamera drin. Mit der Kamera drin, und der Roboterpinguin kommt dann zur Pinguinfamilie. Wird aufgenommen. Wird aufgenommen und die alle einfach so ... Weird. Aber sie können das nicht kommunizieren. Lachen sie? Ja.
Sie können nicht sagen ...
Nee, teilweise so ein bisschen gucken.
Glaubst du, Tiere sind ... Man sagt ja, Tiere sind cool, was sie für ein Herz haben, die sind so toll.
Hört man ständig.
Tiere sind die besseren Menschen, hört man ja häufig.
Glaubst du, sie sind nur besser, weil sie das nicht kommunizieren können?
Sie können nämlich sagen, verpiss dich, du Loser.
Hau ab, so einen wie dich wollen wir hier nicht.
Du metallener Loser-Klotz.
Ja.
Du metallener Kamera-Loser-Klotz. Wir hassen dich, du passt nicht, du siehst anders aus als wir. Wir mögen dich nicht. Können sie nicht kommunizieren und deswegen ist das gleiche einfach wie ihn aufnehmen. Ja, aber was ich gerne machen würde, ist, ich würde auch so eine Doku machen mit so einem Roboter-Pinguin und dann aber irgendwann sagen, ja, er freundet sich mit den anderen Pinguinen an. Und dann sagt man so eines Tages ... So Baseballspielen, die werden so ... Hin und her und ... Und er ist so wie so ein Torpedo, so achtmal so schnell wie alle anderen und die anderen so ... Und dann eines Tages kommt dann so die Forscherin vor die Kamera und meint, naja, und dann haben wir Pingo, haben wir nicht mehr gefunden. Wir wissen nicht, wo er ist. Wie? Wie haben Sie nicht mehr gefunden. Es war sehr teuer, dieses Roboter-Arte. Also wir wissen, wir können ihn nicht mehr finden unter den Pinguinen. Wieso nicht? Wir können es nicht unterscheiden. Sie können es nicht unterscheiden. Wir wissen nicht mehr, wo er ist. Wir haben die Kontrolle über ihn verloren. Das Kamerabild ist abgerissen. Alle Pinguine töten. Wir wissen nicht, wo er ist.
Das ist die logische Konsequenz.
Wirklich?
Ich als Antagonist dieses Disney-Films.
Ich dachte, Sie sind der Redakteur von einem Dokumentarfilm.
Naja, aber wenn wir nicht mehr wissen, wer Ping Pongo, der Pinguin, der Roboter-Pinguin ist.
Ja.
Das ist wie Robocop.
Ping Pong.
Nur mit Ping Pong.
King Kong.
Okay.
Ich hätte mir bei dem Namen schon merken müssen, dass es eine Gefahr ist.
Aber er hat eine Artificial Intelligence in sich eingebaut. Ja. Er lernt. Aber die kann auch lernen. Eben. Und dann ist er weg. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt alle Pinguine umbringen, damit wir sicher gehen, dass Pongo der Pinguin weg ist. Und das so als Fake-Doku über Pinguine und es hört halt so rapide auf. Und der Zuschauer denkt sich, da ist jetzt ein Roboter-Pinguin, der normal lebt wie alle anderen, was passiert da? Nice. Aber niemand weiß es. Nice, gefällt mir gut. Ich finde generell eine Dokumentation, die wirklich so, nicht wie ein Mockumentary, wo man kurz denkt, ah, ist das wirklich passiert, sondern einfach eine Dokumentation, die wirklich eine Hälfte sehr lehrreiche, gute Dokumentation ist und dann hart abdriftet. Ja Das fände ich geil. So wirklich fast so 60 Minuten lang ganz normale Doku über Eisbären. Ja. Ganz normal. Ja. Und dann driftet es ab, wie ein Eisbärenbiby plötzlich so weggeht, und dann hinter so einer Lichtung ist so ein merkwürdiges Objekt gelandet. Und dann geht er so dahin und geht dann so da rein, und dann sieht man so Blitze und so. Und es wird nicht, es wird genauso kommentiert, genauso. Die kleinen Eisbären können sich immer für neue Dinge begeistern. Die Neugier treibt ihn dazu, immer neue Dinge zu lernen. Hier zum Beispiel ist ein merkwürdiges, dreieckiges Gefilde gelandet mitten in der Arktis. Sie spielen damit herum. Oh, ein paar grelle Lichtplätze.
Am nächsten Tag konnten wir den kleinen Bimbel nicht mehr finden. Die Familie zieht jetzt ohne ihn weiter. Wo ist er? Wo ist Bimbel? Und es wird einfach ganz normal behandelt, und es driftet so mega ab. Ja.
In so einem weirden Shit.
Oder man behauptet so, dann kommt Pickfordfoot durch und man behauptet auch, dass wir ein ganz normales Tier. Finde ich richtig gut. Aber da verscherzt man sich mit der Dokumentarfilmer-Gilde, die dann irgendwie da keinen Bock mehr drauf haben. Mit beiden eigentlich. Man verscherzt sich sowohl mit den Leuten, die Fiction machen, weil es halt nur eine Hälfte ist, als auch mit den Dokumenten. Also man macht sich nur Feinde. Also man macht sich die ganze Welt zum Feind. Eisbären, Aliens, alle fünf macht man sich zum Feind. Oder ich habe letztens den Film gesehen über den McDonalds-Gründer, finde ich auch gut, so eine Doku über McDonalds. Und dann siehst du den erst so, ja, der hatte immer Ideen und der hat immer überlegt, wie man Restaurants besser machen können und ist durchs ganze Land gefahren. Und so und irgendwann hat er dann irgendwo mal so ein kleines bisschen Land gefunden, da hat er es dann aufgebaut und er hat das so alles systematisch gemacht, dass jeder Burger so ganz schnell gemacht werden kann und arbeitsteilig und sowas. Und dann die grosse Eröffnung und dann der erste Kunde kriegt den ersten Hamburger-Foto, erster Hamburger und ab dann folgen wir nur noch dem Kunden des ersten Hamburger, der das isst. War ganz lecker. Steigt in sein Auto, fährt nach Hause. Und lebt sein normales Leben. Ein normales Leben und dann denkt er sich, habe ich nicht was vergessen? Dann kommt er zu Hause an, sieht das Auto von der Schwester seiner Frau und denkt, oh nein, stimmt, heute wollte ja die Jessie kommen. Jetzt habe ich wieder nichts dabei, die erwartet immer Geschenke, wenn sie zu Besuch kommt. Und dann nimmt er noch irgendwas schnell, fragte die Nachbarin, kann ich noch eine Flasche Wein? Und so einfach, wir vergessen komplett McDonalds. Wir sehen irgendwann im Hintergrund dieses riesigen gelben Bögen oder sowas, wenn er vorbeifährt, vor der Polizei wegfährt. Und es ist einfach völlig im Hintergrund. Dann bist du noch spannend. Es wird noch relativ spannend, muss man sagen. Aber schön, dass du uns das andere erzählt hast, wo er noch dieses Geschenk schnell braucht und eine Weinflasche einpackt, die ihm selber geschenkt wurde. Ich hätte lieber spannender gefunden, jetzt zu wissen, warum er von der Polizei wegfährt. Erfährst du vielleicht im Abspann. Es gibt wahnsinnig viele Texttafeln nach dem Abspann. Wahnsinnig viele Texttafeln. Denken wir immer, es ist faul. Texttafeln am Ende ist wie ein Song, der ausfadet. Okay. Falsch. Eine Faulheit kommt durch.
Das Kunstwerk sagt, hier war man faul.
Man hat nicht klar zu Ende gedacht.
Bringt uns doch die Information in der Dokumentation.
Er hat doch gerade zwei Stunden Zeit, uns alles zu erklären.
Und der Song, bitte komponiert einfach ein fucking Ende.
Das ist genau das Gleiche.
Das ist immer unbefriedigend.
Man denkt sich, warum gehen wir jetzt?
Band fährt weg. Warum gehen wir? Das ist so, als würde man das Konzert zu früh verlassen. Wir ist immer unbefriedigend. Man denkt sich, warum gehen wir jetzt? Band fährt weg.
Warum gehen wir? Das ist so, als würde man das Konzert zu früh verlassen. Wir gehen, während die Musik noch läuft. Warum?
Die Gelehrten streiten sich ja, ob Sweet Home Alabama, der alte Song von Leonard Skinner, ob der in G oder D ist.
Weil er die ganze Zeit nur D, C, G als Akkorde
hatte, die ganze Zeit durchleiern. Man weiß nicht genau, was
der Heimatton.
Und der Song hat einen Fadeout.
Was es noch unmöglicher macht.
Weil normalerweise muss sich dann ja
irgendwann mal jemand entscheiden,
ich ende auf der Heimattonart.
Ein befriedigendes Ende. Also
muss sich Linus Ginnert entscheiden, D
als Ende zu spielen oder das G als Ende zu spielen. Aber weil der Song Fadeout hat, mussten sie diese Entscheidung nie treffen. Das ist unbefriedigend. Das stimmt. Und dann geht man mit diesem Gefühl nach Hause. Das kennt ihr vielleicht, wenn man das Gefühl, wie man Le Bama gehört hat. Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann ein Lied nicht geniessen, wenn ich nicht weiss, was der Heimatakkord ist. Ich denk mir so, ich komm nicht zu Hause an.
Man läuft dann so ein bisschen wild durch den Tag.
Hey, hey, Schatz, hey, hey, Schatz, hey, hey, Schatz, hey, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, hey, Schatz, dem ... Hast du schon wieder ein Lied gehört, was keine Heimattonart hatte? Du weisst, Musik ist meine Heimat, aber manchmal hat man das Gefühl, man hat noch nicht alle Umzugskartons ausgepackt. Verstehst du, wie das ist? Ich habe dir gesagt, du sollst keine Musik mehr hören, die keine klare Heimattonart hat, okay? Ja, ich weiss. Ich weiss, wir haben sehr spezifische Streits, aber wir hatten das Thema, okay? Schatz, wir sind auch durch diesen Streit gekommen und werden auch dadurch kommen, okay? Wir haben die spezifischsten Streits. Ja. Ich habe dir schon tausendmal gesagt, du sollst keine Songs hören, die keine klare Heimat drunter haben. Und ich habe dir gesagt, dass die siebte Staffel Power Rangers nicht so gut ist wie die sechste Staffel, okay? Aber das kam ja nur daher, weil ich so sauer auf dich war, weil du das untere Kühlschrankfach immer mit Tomaten vollpackst. Das untere Kühlschrankfach ist für Tomaten, weil sie am meisten gekühlt werden müssen, weil sie am meisten war... Da ist es. G. Genau. Und dann mussten sie sich nämlich entscheiden, weil sie ja... Pressekonferenz. Sie spielen es... Mr. Skinner, was ist denn nun die Heimat-Tonart von Sweet Home Alabama? Erstmal vielen Dank für die... Also wir haben noch nicht gesagt, woher Sie kommen, von welchem News-Outlet Sie kommen. Ich komme von den Rolling Stones. Okay, vielen Dank, Herr Jagger, für diese Frage. Nein, von den Magazinen Rolling Stones. Ach so, von einem gesammelten Rolling Stones-Magazin. Der heißt Rolling Stone. Nein, es sind ja nicht nur ein Magazin, es sind die Rolling Stones, mehrere Magazine. Die Bravos. Okay, die Architektur-Variante der Rolling Stones oder was? Nein, nein. Denken Sie, wir haben nur eine Ausgabe, wir haben noch mehrere Ausgaben. Ja, okay. Ich schreibe für die Rolling Stones, für die verschiedenen Ausgaben. Aber man sagt ja auch nicht die Bild-Zeitungen. Ich bin Bild-Zeitungen-Regisseur. Natürlich. Nee, Bild-Zeitungs-Regisseur. Nein, nein, nein, ich arbeite bei den Bild-Zeitungen. Glauben Sie, es gibt immer nur eine Zeitung? Das ist die Zeit, das sind nicht die Zeiten. Nein, nein, es gibt aber mehr als eine Ausgabe. Wenn Sie am Supermarkt eine Zeitung kaufen, dann ist das nicht die einzige Ausgabe, die es gibt. Wir haben riesige Druckerpressen, wo die sozusagen, ja, wie erkläre ich es Wo die sozusagen man hat einen so einen Drucksatz, man hat einen so einen Druckersatz. Sie fangen viel zu früh an. Tiefdruck. Sie fangen viel zu früh an mit der Erklärung. Das wird gesetzt, dass alle gleich sind. Mehr zum Druck. Und dann kannst du quasi beliebig naja, also wie hoch ist die Auflage? Ja, das braucht ja alles gar nicht so sehr wissen. 50, 60 Tausend in der ersten Nacht. So, und dann wird das ja alles erstmal ausgeliefert. Das heißt, es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Rolling Stones. Gleich, wieder gleich. Das ist mir schon klar, genau. Aber man würde, glaube ich, eher sagen, ich arbeite für den Rolling Stone. Ich arbeite für die Zeit. Die Leute würden ja denken, dann hätte man eine Zeitschrift geschrieben. Die ganze. Niemand denkt das. Oder ich arbeite für die deutsche Zeitung. Oder zum Beispiel, ich arbeite für die Hütte. Ich arbeite für die Deutsche Zeitung N. Sonst ergibt es ja keinen Sinn. D. Gut, dann haben wir es doch. Mein Gott, ey. Das Cover für die nächste Ausgabe der Rolling Stones. Ein großes D. Einfach nur D. Ein Riesend in wunderschönen Serifen. Wie viele Serifen kriegst du maximal an so einen D dran? Zwei. Zwei Serifen, Serifen. Das ist wie ein Schlagring. Magst du lieber Serifenschriften oder Serifenlose Schriften? Wann haben wir euch verloren eigentlich? Bei welcher Folge haben wir euch verloren? Warum sind wir nicht erfolgreich als gemischte Sack? Mögt ihr lieber Serifenschriften oder Serifenlose Schriftenlaubt ihr, Lennart Skinnard, äh, Leute, bitte antwortet, sonst machen wir nicht weiter. D oder G, oder ist es doch Fiss? Ja, weil du die Leute anschreist. Ja, ich mag Serifen mag ich schon auch. Es ist immer wie diese kleine Rutsche, wie so eine kleine, ich bin ja Skater, und da kann man sich immer, also Serifen sind bei Buchstaben so diese kleinen Sockel. Skater. Doch, doch, doch, ich bin Skater, ich konnte früher ein Darkslide, und heute kann ich noch einen Olli und einen Default. Und bei diesen Serifen kann man sich immer so vorstellen, so, weißt du, wenn du wie ein Skater denkst, I'm just a skater boy, you're just a skater girl, so we're gonna be skater girls. She said see you later boy. Yeah. And he was a skater boy. And indeed she did see me later, Guy. He was a skater boy. She said see you later, boi, Guy. Guy? Boy of boy? She was a skater boy. He was a skater boy. I'm a skater girl, you're a Skaterboy. We were some Skater guys. Ja, Skater crowd. Friend group. Skater group, ja. Ein Rudel, sozusagen im Deutschen. Skater troop. Skater troop. A destiny. Ja. A destiny of ... Also, ne, aber ich denk mir immer so, als Skater hast du immer so den Gesamtblick für alles. Du siehst ja so einen Skatepark und denkst dir sofort, wo kann ich überall hin?
Und wenn ich ein Buch sehe, denke ich auch, okay, hoch am P, Olli, Slide, übers F, runter ins N, richtig einen Anlauf nehmen, ins U.
Anstrengend, wenn es zu lesen ist.
Wie viele Bücher hast du gelesen?
Kann man noch Bücher lesen. Lest gerade die Goebbels-Biografie? Kein Wort verstanden.
Kein Wort verstanden.
Du warst die ganze Zeit bei der Goebbels-Biografie mit dem Skate-Börtchen. U, E, E, B, L, runter. Wann hat er die geschrieben? Die hat er nicht selber geschrieben. Er hat ein Tagebuch geschrieben, deswegen ist es auch relativ lame, weil die immer nur sagt in der Biografie. Und dann hat er im Tagebuch geschrieben dies und das, dann nenne ich mehr, das kriege ich auch noch hin. Vor allem, ich habe auch gedacht, das ist auch ein Rückschritt für Biografen, dass gerade alle aufhören, Tagebücher zu führen, sondern auch nur diesen Mut. Es gibt ja dann so Leute, die jetzt dann so mit Farben ausmalen mit Grün, Rot, Orange und Gelb, wie gut der Tag war. Da muss man, wie gut habe ich geschlafen, Schlafqualität, primär Schlafen, gute Laune, wie gut ist die Laune, wie viel hat man gemacht, hat man sich produktiv gefühlt und so weiter. Und da muss man es immer ausmalen. Und das ist natürlich cool und am Ende gibt es schöne Farben. Wenn ich dann beauftragt werde, irgendwie über Lisa F eine Biografie zu schreiben und alles, was ich von ihr habe, sind ihre Eltern, die sagen, Lisaisa war an awesome Skatergirl und sie hat dieses Tagebuch und mein Tagebuch ist aber so ein Mood-Buch, so ein vages, farbiges Mood-Buch. Aber wir haben ja zum Glück noch ihren Instagram-Account, wo sie am 14.8. eine Monstera-Pflanze das Bild von einer ausgedrückten Zigarettenkippe gepostet hat mit der Caption Mood.
Und jetzt müssen wir gucken.
Das ist ein gutes Cover.
Was ist das?
Das kann vieles bedeuten.
Naja, weil sie hat so einen überlaufenden Mülleimer gepostet mit der Caption Mood.
Und jetzt müssen wir da so ein bisschen gucken.
An dem Tag war auch ihr Mood-Tagebuch ziemlich rot.
Heißt, es ging ihr nicht gut, vielleicht weil sie das Gefühl hat, sie ist übergequillt. Ja Sinne von, es ist zu viel los, es schlummert zu viel in mich, jemand muss mich nicht mehr lernen. Lehren. Und dann hat sie noch ein Bild gepostet von einem Feuerzeug mit dem Hashtag Mood. Sehr viel brauchen. Oh, gut, guck mal, du bist ein guter Biograph. Ja, ich hasse meinen Job. Du kannst direkt, weil die Aufgabe eines Biographen, ähnlich wie beim Skater, ist ja eigentlich die gleiche Idee. Skater? Skater, du versuchst den roten Faden durch den Skatepark zu finden. Der Biograph sieht ein Leben, wo andere nur Bruchstücke sehen, nur so eine Celebrations-Schüssel. Siehst den roten Faden, die Dramaturgie. Siehst du den roten Faden, genau. Du bist wie das Kinderpingui, du hast diesen roten Streifen. Alle anderen sind nur so eine Schüssel Celebrations. Das ist kein Gesamtkonzept, das sind einfach willkürliche Elemente. Du hingegen, du siehst den roten Faden. Findest du ernsthaft? Ich glaube, du kannst das richtig gut. Findest du, dass Celebrations eine willkürliche Anheignung bringt? Ja, absolut. Halbes und nichts Ganzes, da konnte man sich nicht entscheiden. Das ist einfach klassisches Komitee.
Anscheinend ist unser Herrgott anderer Meinung. Ihr hört das leider nicht wahrscheinlich, aber die Glocken von Athen donnern uns hier um die Ohren und wollen uns erinnern. Das ist so schade, der Moment, wo ich herausgefunden habe, dass Kirchenglocken ja einfach ein Knopf sind, auf den man drückt. Oder wahrscheinlich ist es inzwischen einfach eine Zeitschaltruhe. Aber früher, das Wissen, dass da jemand gerade hochgekraxelt ist bei 32 Grad in Köln und dann oben steht an so einem Seil und diese Glocken macht, das finde ich so eine geile Vorstellung, dass da gerade oben jemand steht und ballert. Aber es gibt tatsächlich noch manuelle Glockentürme. Ich habe extra mal, ich habe Glöckner von Notre Dame recherchiert und dann habe ich auch gesehen, es gibt tatsächlich noch Glöckner, die haben wie so eine Art riesiges Metall, also wie so eine Heavy Metal Band, so ein riesiges metallisches 70% Folterinstrument, 30% Klavier, wo du halt wirklich so grosse Knöpfe hast, wo du so glung, glung, glung und es klingt immer schrecklich, klingt immer furchtbar und ich weiß nicht genau, was die Idee dahinter ist und die haben dann auch so Handschuhe. Lautstärke ist die Idee. Ja genau, die haben dann auch so Handschuhe an, also wie wenn du jetzt vorstellst, du hast Klavier, wo du mit der Taste draufdrücken kannst, ganz sanft. Stell dir vor, diese Tasten sind fünfhundertmal so fest, so dass man wirklich so mit diesen Stahlhandschuhen so drauf
schlagen muss. Es ist eine ganz absurde
Situation, weil es ist ja immer noch Musik,
aber Musik für, als wäre dieses
Instrument nicht für Menschen gebaut worden. Für Handwerker,
Musik für Schmiede. Als er wäre das so eine
verschollene Riesenzivilisation,
wo wir die Instrumente noch haben und dann
äh, äh,
das ist einfach nicht für uns. Lass mich doch mal.
Und dann kommt so Fasold, der Riese und der muss muss einfach so spielen. Und der spielt es dann einfach wunderschön. Aber von außen ist es einfach nur Glocken, die einfach die Stadt zum Schwingen bringen. Wunderschön. Die Glocken, die die Stadt zum Schwingen bringen. Die Glocken, die die Stadt zum Schwingen bringen. Dieser Roman, den haben Sie nun innerhalb der letzten vier Jahre geschrieben. Wir haben ja ewig drauf gewartet. Korrekt, ich habe mir eine kleine Loft in Valencia geholt und wurde jeden Tag von den Glocken ins Realitätsbewusstsein zurückgedonnert. Wofür steht das? In der Geschichte geht es ja um die kleine Lisa, die auch wie ein, sagen wir mal, wie ein Mülleimer, der überquillt. Richtig, richtig, die kleine Lisa, die sich fühlt wie ein Klöppel einer grossen Glocke, die hin und her geworfen wird von den gesellschaftlichen Strömen. Sie ist quasi wie ein kleines Stöckchen im Fluss der Geschichte. So gehört sie, sie weiss es nicht. Sie weiss es nicht, sie weiss es nicht. Sie weiss nur, dass wenn sie an ein Extrem herandonnert, dann macht das Geräusche, dann kriegen das alle mit. Vier Jahre, zwölf Seiten. Dabei muss die Frage erlaubt sein, ist das nicht ein bisschen wenig? Nein, nein, Sie werden merken, dass diese Seiten es in sich haben, also dass die wirklich so dicht formuliert sind. Die sind gross bedruckt, sehr dicht, aber gross bedruckt, grosse Buchstaben, nur zwölf Seiten, ab wann ist ein Buch ein Buch? Korrekt, gute Frage, die mein Buch auch anreisst, aber nicht wirklich behandelt. Zwölf Seiten sind eine Menge.
Nein, aber ich will doch riesen Geschichte.
Zwölf Seiten sind eine Menge.
Eine Minute ist lang, zwölf Seiten sind eine Menge.
Auf jeden Fall.
Es kommt ja natürlich auch auf die Lesegeschwindigkeit an.
Mein Buch ist ein Buffet und ich mache ein Buffet auf.
Und ein Buffet sagt man ja auch nicht,
oh, das kann ich ja alles schnell wegessen, das ist ja alles kleinteilig.
Doch.
Sondern wenn man jedes Buchstaben... Jedes Buffet sagt. Wie viel kann ich essen, bis ich es wieder zumachen? Wie viel kann ich jetzt gerade essen, wie viel ist es gesellschaftlich erlaubt? Das ist ein enges Bild von Buffets, also da würde ich jetzt sagen, da habe ich in Valencia andere Buffets. Wie oft kann ich zu Pizza greifen, bis jemand sagt, so jetzt haben Sie aber schon genug von der Pizza gegessen, und wie lange hat das Buffet auf? Alles dreht sich darum, wie lange es auf hat. Und wie viel Shrimp gibt's? Und gibt's also... Ich weiß auch immer, und das ist auch noch eine sehr deutsche Einstellung, aber wie kann ich die am meisten, das hat auch mal Kumpel gesagt, er hat gesagt, bei Buffets denkt er immer, wie kann ich die am meisten verletzen? Und mir gefällt alles daran. Mir gefällt, dass es so martialisch ist, mir gefällt, dass er von dieser ominösen Die spricht, was wie so eine Verschwörungstheorie ist und die da oben Energie hat. Aber eigentlich geht es um Leute, die ein Buffet erstellen. Und er geht dann da hin und sagt, wie kann ich die jetzt am meisten verletzen? Mehr Fleisch nehmen, die Schrimps, immer die teuersten Sachen nehmen, die grosse Kilogramme oder Literpreise haben. Diese Dinge nimmt er sich immer. Aber ich finde das eine sehr lustige Einstellung, zu einem Buffet zu gehen, eigentlich, ach, was esse ich jetzt, Schatz, was isst du, und er denkt, wie kann ich die da oben am meisten verletzen? Du magst doch gar keine Shrimp. Schatz, es ist unangenehm, dir zuzugucken. Du bist allergisch gegen Shrimp. Da schadet den am meisten. Ein Kilopreis Shrimp bei den Temperaturen ist mindestens 28 Euro. Du bist allärisch gegen Kaviar. Warum isst du den goldenen Bilderrahmen auf? Die Serviette. Die Servietten sind nicht teuer, Schatz. Die Servietten sind richtig teuer, die sind bestickt. Ach Gott, die Tisch-Servietten. So ein bisschen wie Super-Toys-Club, wo du so durch die Gegend rennen kannst und dann einfach alles, alles packst und dann einfach so, wie kann ich dir da, geil fände ich auch mal Super Toys Club und der packt die nicht ein, sondern der macht die einfach kaputt, nimmt einfach den Fernseher und einfach sagt, wie kann ich den am meisten schaden, wie kann ich den am meisten wehtun, das ganze Regal einfach umgeschmissen, wann würde jemand eingreifen und sagen, was passiert hier eigentlich? Wann wird Commander David zum Commander eigentlich? Genau, ja, das stimmt. Der wurde nie zum Commander. Ist der noch im Dienst? Wann wird der nochmal aufs Schlachtfeld gerufen? Lieutenant David ist es jetzt. Aber das finde ich auch fantastisch. Einfach durchgehen, einfach alles kaputt machen. Wenn du einfach kein Interesse an dem Format hast, sondern einfach nur Schaden anrichten. Ich kenne das, bei Buffets habe ich immer, habe ich schon alles gegessen, was ich bezahlt habe. Das ist mein Mindset. Die ganze Zeit. Alles in allem ist das ein furchtbares Konzept. All you can eat ist immer schrecklich, weil du bist immer im Kampf mit dir selber. Ich muss noch mehr essen, ich habe bezahlt, ich muss noch viel mehr essen, ich kann mehr essen. Das ist einfach schrecklich. Ja genau, es ist auch nie geil. Überall vermutet man so eine kleine Verschwörungstheorie so, ah, jetzt haben die immer mehr Soße reingemacht. Und da sind sehr wenig Fleischbällchen in der Soße. Überall erwartet man so, wie können die mir jetzt wehtun, wie kann ich denen wehtun? Das Konzept Eulkenit ist so gut, dass man immer auf der Hut ist und denkt, die wollen mich, die kriegen mich. Wo kriegen die mich gerade? Irgendwas, also das ist zu gut, um wahr zu sein. Aber es fühlt sich an wie ein Schachspiel, aber es sollte ja sein, wie so Schiffe versenken oder Risiko, so fühlt es sich an. Es sollte ja sein, die kochen für mich, ich freue mich, vielen Dank, ich kann viel essen. Aber es ist eher so, man sucht nach, wie sind sie mir einen Schritt voraus, wie kann ich ihnen wieder einen Schritt voraus sein? Schach ist wie Schach, Buffet ist wie Schach, nur ohne Würfel. Du musst, ja, es ist unbefriedigend. Ich glaube, je weniger du hast, desto besser ist es auch natürlich. Deswegen Hähnchenwagen zum Beispiel. Du weißt, was du bekommst. Du weißt, was du bekommst. Du siehst, was du bekommst. Und ein kleiner Shoutout an Hähnchenwagenbesitzer in der Temperatur, weil wir alle schwitzen, aber niemand schwitzt so sehr wie Udos Hähnchengrill, der einfach selber mitgegrillt wird, in eigenem Saft einfach auch noch selber brutzelt. Okay, das stimmt. Das stimmt. Und der einfach vor sich hin brutzelt und am Ende des Tages einfach nach Hause käufer knusprig ist. Müssen sich Hähnchenwagenbesitzer auch häufiger mal um die eigene Achse drehen, weil es von hinten zu heiß wird? Ja, es kann sein. Weil hinten ist die jetzt eine Komponente. Sich mitdrehen. Oder die haben halt am Ende, passt bitte auf, ihr müsst euch drehen,
sonst ist am Ende euer Rücken komplett knuswig gebacken. Sehe mir vor, du bestellst, ich krieg ein halbes Hähnchen. Und man sagt so, ja, komm sofort. Und dann dreh sich um und du siehst die ganze Rückseite, ist kross, ist wunderschön, ist wunderschön, kässlich, kross, goldbraun gebacken. Goldbraun. Und man denkt, und dann dreht man sich, ja hier, bitteschön.
Und dann kriegst du ein halbes Hähnchen, ne?
Ja, aber dein ganzes, also das, was du bestellst.
Ja, aber es ist, ich glaube, das ist Standardbestellung oder man macht halbes Hähnchen.
Also das ist das Verhältnis.
Ja, ich bestelle meistens zwei halbe Hähnchen.
Okay, aber dann legst du Wert darauf, dass es die Hälften des gleichen Huhns ist.
Das ist spannend.
Und am Ende kriegst du zwei Linke und du sagst, Männchen mal, Uwe, da hast du mich jetzt aber betrogen. Das finde ich spannend. Ich glaube, man kriegt zwei halbe Hähnchen von verschiedenen Hähnchen. Aber immer wenn ich mein Mann zu zweit isst, hole ich immer zwei halbe Hähnchen, weil ich will ja nicht selber in der Küche die Gartenzange rausholen, wo ich das Hähnchen durchballere. Ich liebe Hähnchen, ganz toll. Aber es ist so geil, dass das Verhältnis Mensch zu Huhn einfach zwei zu eins ist. Also ein Huhn, zwei Menschen. Es ist einfach, ich meine, bei keinem anderen Tier sagst du, oh, jetzt sind wir so ein zwanzigsten Rind oder sowas. Aber es gibt kein Perfekt. So ein Achtzehntel Ziege. Aber wo ist denn das perfekte Tier? Welches Tier kannst du, jeder Mensch ein Tier? Fisch. Fisch ist eine Mahlzeit ein Tier. Fisch ist eine Mahlzeit ein Tier, Kartoffeln.
Ja, beim Händchen ist ja auch was dabei.
Na, aber ein Fisch?
Jetzt wird aber die Diskussion wild.
Ja, hast du beim Händchen Beilagen oder was?
Ja, klar, das sind Beilagen.
Was stopfst du dir da noch dazu ein?
Ja, zum Beispiel stopp ich mir einen Kartoffelsalat ins Mundloch, daneben noch.
Kartoffelsalat?
Ja klar, Kartoffelsalat.
Wo kriegst du den denn?
Aus dem Rewe oder Lidl oder Kaufland. Du gehst nach dem Grillwagen noch mal in Kaufland? Nee, es ist ein Walk. Was zuerst? Pff, Hähnchen nicht, weil es ist natürlich geil, wenn es noch ein bisschen heiß ist, mit dem Hähnchenmann noch so viel gross, oder ich packe es noch mal in den Backofen. Okay, spannend, okay. Es ist so spannend. Fisch ist Hähnchen. gemischtes Handbesser? Fisch ist. Ich finde, Fisch ist eine Mahlzeit. Ein Fisch, eine Mahlzeit. Klar, kommt doch hier auf den Fisch an. Also so ein Walhai, viel zu viel. Fischstäbchen? Viel zu viel. Fischstäbchen, Fische, zu klein. Aber so ein schöner, großer Rotbarsch oder sowas ist schon, glaube ich, einfach perfekte Grösse, Dorsch. Aber es ist echt, wirklich, wie die schwitzen müssen, ich habe echt das Gefühl, denen einfach ein kaltes, also kann ich ihnen was bringen, weil die da wirklich zu gründigen, wir alle schwitzen gerade und es ist schrecklich. Aber ganz kurz, ganz kurz mal eben, weil wir müssen noch aufräumen mit diesen paar Mythen, die es gibt. Müde Mythen? Ich bin den Mythen. Sind wir eigentlich immer noch in der Kategorie, oh shit. Aber dieses, man darf kein kaltes Wasser trinken im Sommer oder keine kalten Getränke mit Eiswürfeln, weil das regt einen Kreislauf an und du schwitzt. Warm darfst du nicht trinken, weil dann schwitzt du. Das ist alles eine loose-loose Situation für alle alle Sein Zitat oder jetzt von jemand anderem? Nee, nee, ist die Frage Niemand, Stefan, niemand versteht, wie Hitze funktioniert Niemand weiß, was man tun soll, wenn es heiß ist Wenn die Wohnung kalt werden soll Checkt niemand, hör auf Ventilatoren machen nicht Es sind alles einfach nur Entschuldigungen, Ventilator war die einzige, die die Menschheit je hatte, lass uns das einfach wegwirbeln Wirbeln, wird nicht wegwirbeln Und war's, Ende. Wirb nicht wegwirbeln. Wirb nicht wegwirbeln, Zirkulation, das ist alles Bullshit. Aber es reagiert mit der Haut. Wir sind machtlos. Wir sind machtlos. Oh Gott. Wir sind einfach komplett ausgeliefert der Hitze. Es wird nichts. Ein Lehrer wird so emotional bei einem Kind, was sagt, wie genau funktioniert Hitze eigentlich? Wir geben auf, wir haben den Kampf verloren, Udo. Wir sind komplett geliefert, wir sind das Hähnchen am Grill, wir rotieren seit 30 Jahren.
Was reden Sie? Wir kommen da nicht mehr raus.
So, Lehrerkollegen kommen so rein. Sir, ich war außer mir.
Warum reden Sie von Hähnchen? Sie unterrichten doch Sachunterricht.
Leg dir was Kaltes auf den Kopf. Leg dir eine Packung Erbsen auf dem Kopf oder sowas.
Habe ich jetzt überlegt, Ventilator. Das regt deinen Kreislauf an. Hört auf, dein Kreislauf anzuregen. Im Ernst. Ventilator und dann aber so wie so Pizzen. Stell dir vor, du hast den Ventilator und dann drei Tiefkühlpizzen so wie so Klingen vor den Ventilator, so dass die ganze Luft nicht mehr durchkommt. Im genau 90 Grad Winkel, dass die Luft genau durch die Pizzen durchgeht, also an ihnen flang, so dass du das ist ein Opfer, das ich gerne bereit bin zu geben, und dadurch wird die Luft gekühlt und dir ins Gesicht geblasen. Kalt und schnell. So muss die Luft sein. Wenn das geht, dann wäre das die beste Lösung. Aber man soll auch nicht kalt duschen, weil auch Kreislauf anregend. Würdest du sagen, würdest du den Deal eingehen, wenn jemand sagt, der ganze Schweiss deines Körpers wird nur noch über einen Quadratzentimeter an deinem Körper geschwitzt, wenn du selber festlegen kannst, wo dieser Quadratzentimeter ist. Ich habe Fragen. Schwitze ich genauso viel wie jetzt? Ja, Schwitzvolumen ist gleich viel, es wird nur auf eine Stelle des Körpers konzentriert, ein Quadratzentrum. Im Laufe des Tages spritzt es dann, wenn ich doll schwitze, einfach raus. Währenddessen, ob es zu Spritzungen kommt oder nicht, das ist dann von dem Volumen abhängig. Das ist wie ein Walfisch, ehrlich gesagt, wo oben dann immer so eine... Und wo würdest du die Stelle hin machen? So im Nacken oder so, wie so ein Wal, der immer so nach hinten ...
Aber dann läuft sie ja komplett in den Rücken runter.
Nee, Idee. Bisschen Heck. Bisschen heckige Idee.
Aber wahrscheinlich irgendwo unten.
Fuß oder wie?
Nee, da wo ...
Knöchel?
Nee, nee, da wo auch schon andere Flüssigkeiten rauskommen und oder Stuhl.
Und würde dann da wie so ein Tampon reinstecken. So etwas wie ein Tampon. Da müsste man noch überlegen, wie genau man das ... Was irgendwie so Flüssigkeiten auffällt irgendwie, aber wie sowas. Also da müsste ja was geben. Ich habe jetzt gerade, habe ich irgendwie wie so Brett vorm Kopf, aber irgendwas in der Richtung muss es geben.
Weißt du, wäre das zu clever, mache ich den Witz kaputt?
Du würdest es in Schritt?
In den Arsch.
Um deinen ganzen Tag komplett durchgehendes Flüssiges ...
Ich würde einen Tampon im Hintern stecken, was das auffällt.
Aber gut, jetzt natürlich, klar, ich kann jetzt auch meine Ellenbogenkehle machen. Elle, Ellenkehle. Ja. Und da kann ich auch Tampon reinstecken. Ich glaube, ich würde so am Knöchel, seitlich, am Fuss einfach so eine Art Auslauf und dann so eine Regenrinne da hinbauen oder so im Schuh. Fuss, aber im Schuh? Ja, aber du baust so eine kleine Regenrinne oder sowas. Aus dem Schuh raus. Ja, aber so, ne, denk jetzt doch mal so Knöchel oder so hinten Knöchel, Achillessehne, Ach Achillessehne. Aber dann läufst du irgendwie. Und da hast du so eine kleine Regenrinne, die hinten einfach hinter dir alles vollspitzt. Dann läufst du Marco und Andrea und dann der gute Flucati. Was machst du im Raum? Was machst du im Raum? Was machst du im Raum? Du kannst es nicht, du kannst deine Regenrinne. Tampon ist eine super Idee. Also du würdest den Deal nicht eingehen? Oder würdest du ihn eingehen mit deiner Strategie?
Dass man nicht mehr schwitzt und dann Tampon einmacht.
Du hast nur noch den einen Quadratzendel.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich glaube, ich würde den Deal eingehen, weil ich schwitze überall, meine Shirts sind immer durch.
Ich ist super nervig. Überall kommt Fries heraus.
Aber es ist auch gut, wenn man ein Spiel schwitzt, habe ich mal gehört. Aber es sind auch Leute, die in allem Positives sehen.
Diese verdammten Optimisten! Mann, wie ich sie hasse! Irgendwas muss doch schlecht sein in der Welt! Es ist gut, in Hass liegt auch eine Menge Befreiung. Nein! Halt deinen Maul! Wenn auch ihr schwitzt, dann macht jetzt irgendwas und ihr wisst oder nicht was tun und fächert oder?
Fächert, fächert euch das, aber nicht den Kreislauf anregen, bitte. Auch beim Fächern ist wieder die Gefahr gross. Die Gefahr ist generell gross. Bleibt liegen. Bleibt liegen, regt euch nicht, regt los. Und so eine Stunde Tiefkühlpizza voll im Ventilator knallen.